est-ce qu'on est bon au niveau des
Corinne des véhicules
les derniers petits détails avec un bon
coup de nettoyage et on sera prêt ce
sont les ultimes préparatifs car dans un
mois ces véhicules paraderont devant
près de 12 millions de spectateurs
massés sur les bords des routes du Tour
de France un rendez-vous un manque câble
alors tout est misé sur l'esthétique
l'idée c'est vraiment d'avoir des des
choses assez hautes qui prennent de
l'ampleur de l'espace l'intérêt aussi de
ces véhicules c'est qu'il soit beau qui
plaisent le Tour de France c'est une
parade c'est un spectacle c'est pour ça
qu'on a des couleurs qui sont assez
flamboyantes alors certes aux couleurs
des marques mais qu'on a envie de
montrer comme étant des couleurs
festives joyeuses donc vraiment à
l'image de ce qu'est le Tour de France
qui est une grande fête
mais avant le résultat final il y a
toute la fabrication dans cette entrepôt
depuis deux mois une vingtaine
d'artisans travaillent pour les marques
de la caravane publicitaire ici les
peintres et les sculpteurs finalisent
les statues en polystyrène qui seront
édifiées sur le toit des véhicules
certaines font plus de 3 mètres un peu
plus loin les chars sont eux aussi
encore en préparation tous ont été
conçus à partir de camions achetés
d'occasion
complètement donc là il est déjà un peu
aménagé mais on récupère la base donc on
coupe on coupe la cabine on commence à
habiller le véhicule donc là on est dans
l'atelier de la fabrique avec des
structures métalliques en fait qui sont
reprises sur le châssis du véhicule
voilà donc là on aura aussi ici par
exemple un animateur donc il sera debout
avec un micro et qui va s'adresser au
public à quelques semaines du départ de
la Grande Boucle tout est quasiment prêt
l'emblématique caravane devrait être une
nouvelle fois ravir les yeux des
spectateurs